- I'm excited to meet you.
- I'm excited.
- I was so excited to have you on the show
but I know you already
actually know Meghan, right?
This is the Droege family, by the way,
but you already know Meghan, right?
- [Ron] Hello.
- I haven't seen you in so long.
- I know.
- You look amazing.
- Thank you, you look great.
- Thank you so much.
(laughs)
- Yeah, Meghan and I
we met a long time ago
on a show I was on called "Undateable"
and came, and we had fun, we hit it off,
and she gave me her number
and said, "Let's hang out,
"and just talk and chat,"
and I called her and it
just went, "do do doop."
(laughs)
So I been waiting to see you.
(audience laughs and applauds)
- So, hey, Ron, don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it, Ron,
the number I gave you
is totally gonna work,
just keep calling it,
just keep calling it.
(laughs)
- My phone number has changed
three times, this isn't a lie.
Dad, Papa, stand up for me.
- [Kelly] Papa.
- [Papa] Yeah, yeah, at least.
- I had to change my number
at least three times so.
Yeah, I never got a call.
(laughs)
- That was so rude, Ron (laughs).
- It happens.
It's okay.
- I heard you started singing lessons
though recently.
- I did, yeah.
'Cause I've been doing a lot
of voiceovers and cartoons,
we're both in the "Trolls" movie
together.
- We are,
we're both in the "World Tour,"
yeah.
- Congrats.
(audience applauds)
I love that.
- That's amazing, I
totally forgot about that.
They do have us singing a lot,
and, yeah.
- They have us singing a lot
and singing as a cartoon voice,
and I'm like, "I can't sing regularly,
"so why you trying to make
me sing as a giraffe?"
That's crazy.
(laughs)
- 'Cause it probably
sounds really fun (laughs).
- Yes, he's got longer
throat, he got velvety voice.
(laughs)
- That's awesome.
- But I was like, "Let me
get some singing lessons in,"
because I think that's the
only thing I'm missing.
I'm already hilarious,
I'm already very handsome.
(audience applauds)
- [Meghan] Amen, yes.
- You're like a triple threat.
That's what you're working on.
- Yeah, I'm trying
to become a triple threat.
And then you know, just
take over the world.
- I love it.
Well, I feel like your dreams
are gonna become a reality
because you're really into something
that helps those dreams
come a reality, right?
- I am.
Lately I've been big into making
what I call "vision boards," dream boards.
- Oh I know vision boards.
- Yes, I have one.
Oh yeah, in Nashville, that's--
- Do y'all have vision boards?
- Well we made notebooks,
we cut out newspaper articles,
and magazine pictures,
and made notebooks for our travels.
- Oh my gosh, I love it.
What's on your vision board?
- I got it for you
right here.
- You have a vision board.
- Let me show it to you.
- You're sneaky, Ron.
- I brought it.
- [Kelly] Oh my God Australia.
- I had it on there,
and went to Australia,
and I did comedy there in April.
So that happened.
I'm going to Japan in December.
Hopefully I'm gonna get a baby.
That's my new baby.
(laughs)
- I love it, I love it.
- I'm just trying to stay
committed in everything,
my acting, my comedy, my girlfriend,
just trying to stay committed.
- That's beautiful.
But I do have a question.
You have not one, but
three, pictures of The Rock.
What does this mean?
- What is your point?
(laughs)
- I mean, I love The Rock too.
- Show 'em.
- It's just on your
vision board, that's cool.
- Yeah, I love The Rock, he is amazing.
- [Kelly] You wanna meet him?
- He is the epitome of what
a man should be, to me.
He is perfect, he is
amazing, he is a leader,
he is basically the Beyonce for boys.
(laughs)
(audience applauds)
- He is the Beyonce.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Okay, so is he on your vision board
'cause you wanna work with him?
- I wanna work with him,
I wanna be like him,
I want him to carry me
while I eat ice cream.
(laughs)
(audience applauds)
- I wanna make that a
part of the show somehow.
(laughs)
Okay, but you've accomplished, right?
You said you've been to Australia,
you're going to Japan the end of the year,
where's your other vision board?
- Oh, that's why I was
so excited about it.
I got so much stuff done,
we're only about halfway through the year,
I started adding to my vision board.
- Oh my God.
- And you're in it.
(laughs)
(audience applauds)
- This is pretty great.
Meghan you made it too.
- [Meghan] Am I there?
- You didn't even answer
the phone, but you made it.
(laughs)
- That's me.
- Yeah, that's why she's in the corner.
- Are we just chilling on the couch?
(audience laughs and applauds)
- I'm in the corner.
I made it.
- I made the couch.
(laughs)
Now that's amazing.
You're gonna sing and play with us.
We're gonna ride horses
and off into the sunset.
- [Ron] Absolutely we are.
- I love it.
- [Meghan] I'm reading a book.
- And you're reading a book.
- That's new for me.
(laughs)
- This is all coming together.
- That's like a big deal.
That's my goal.
(laughs)
(audience applauds)
- I love your comedy too,
it's always uplifting,
it's very positive,
it makes me laugh.
- Thank you.
- You're very, very talented.